hello hi Rachel its Tamra whoo Tamra we
started the Catwoman review together
yeah no we were roommates for several
years I saved you from that radioactive
bear on Christmas morning after giving
you my kidney sorry it doesn't ring a
bell
oh I lent you my compact oh I thought
there was the name of Japanese company
or something so have you talked to the
nostalgia critic lately oh I talk to him
all the time
I mean about me being in another review
not much chance of that I very rarely
see him but you said that you see him
all the time and I don't know if this
gig is what you're really looking for I
mean you have to perform you have to act
you've got to do all these different
characters that is exactly what I'm
looking for like to the team I knew
you'd understand
wait no Rachel give you a chance well
this is not a good time to bother the
nostalgia critic he's preparing for his
a big month
what big month mine
she says plase is as tough as Gandalf
geometry class you shall not pass seem
less painful cut scenes in a
circumcision
don't worry Rachel when you wake up
you'll be an entirely new person in fact
we'll both be entirely new people
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's so weird to see Nicholas Cage do
something so sympathetic especially we
are just expecting him to snap at any
minute remember on our wedding day when
we got married by the chef brought out
the wedding cake he left in the oven too
long and I was shouting oh wow that was
such a great impression Oh Rachel you're
not supposed to be happy excited you're
supposed to be afraid because I'm
Nicolas Cage acting like Nicolas Cage oh
sorry I got caught up in the moment you
know being in a sketch with you as
opposed to uh nothing
see you want to do it again no the magic
is gone you only have the power to do
one Nicolas Cage freak out on your life
and you have just wasted it for me Thank
You Rachel no problem sir
looking to save face keep the compact
camera I don't know why anyone would
want to go all the way to Japan just to
get one of those things it just doesn't
make any sense I mean every time hey we
to keep it down I'm trying to talk about
this movie some flaws ability if it was
to happen in real life
oh by the way Malcolm you might want to
put on a little bit more white woman
makeup I can kinda see your mannish
features still shining through critic
can I see you out here for a second the
hell is this
Tamara tried to steal my role by ripping
her face off and exchanging it with mine
wait if you switched faces wouldn't you
have to take your own face off too
uh-huh how did you do that very
carefully oh wait how do I know I'm
talking to the real one then we switched
him back that's Tamara she's the one
who's behind all of us wait what you
want the camel nose review yeah you were
great in that oh my god I will have my
ass off miles watching
that back Hey do you do any impressions
or funny voices I do and they sing no
kidding you're pretty talented uh
actually we switched them back again and
that's Rachel and I'm Tamara I would
just testing you to see if we got the
real one Malcolm fucks this and posture
like a co-worker's worried yes so like
to perform well we're sending you to
Hollywood California
we're performance it's going to die
so long Tamara she'll took a minute so
I'm not gonna lie
looking like that it's gonna be hard to
call you Rachel Rachel Michael call you
Tamra just to keep things easier I think
I can live with that
oh right everything's back to normal so
what do we do now
well like usual we clean up the critics
vomit after he watches a bad movie your
turn
[Music]